[Music]
on this Friday night Money Talks how
much it could cost Tech Titans to pay
for Canadian journalism it seems to have
no connection to the value of news the
push and the pushback a heart-wrenching
year oh wonderful why my life is the way
it is now where did we go wrong the
struggle to move on from the
Saskatchewan stabbing Rampage
an age-old question in the U.S how old
is too old to be a politician the Senate
is the most privileged Nursing Home in
the country and hoop dreams the pivotal
match-up for the Canadian men's
basketball team
[Music]
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with new rules that
could impact how Canadians find their
news and more clarity on who has to
follow them there are now clear
conditions for big tech companies
looking for an exemption to the online
news act according to draft regulations
the ACT will apply to companies that
make more than a billion dollars per
year globally and operate in the search
engine or social media Market they must
also have 20 million or more Canadian
users per month the bill is aimed at
getting companies to compensate the
outlets they link to online but it has
drawn the ire of social media Giants
Google and meta in our top story tonight
Mackenzie gray reports on how much the
conditions could cost them
it's the clarity big Tech has been
waiting for the regulations uh they look
you know fair and balanced from our
perspective and by fair I mean fair to
both Publishers and platforms Federal
officials proposing Google and Facebook
pay at least four percent of their
Canadian revenues to Media organizations
so they avoid contravening the online
news act that's projected to cost Google
172 million and Facebook 62 million
annually but it's a formula that wasn't
previously disclosed seems to have no
connection to the value of news to any
sort of negotiated number it's simply
establishing this four percent fee for
linking to news for these couple of
companies Google says it will study the
regulations closely but meta the parent
company of Facebook and Instagram says
the suggested rules will not impact
their decision to no longer allow
Canadian news on its platforms a choice
that doesn't seem to have impacted
business since the band came in on
August 1st Canadian traffic on meta
platforms hasn't changed they're saying
we're not getting that much value out of
news sometimes we're getting uh grief
out of sharing news content and so you
know you want to make us pay well
sorry we can't we can't be bothered but
one group that still uses meta platforms
liberal members of parliament Global
News reviewed the Facebook and Instagram
pages of all 159 MPS and 98 of them
continue to use the platform after the
news ban came into place
many of the posts from around their
ridings some talking about what they ate
but others complained about Facebook on
Facebook Facebook decided that Canadians
can no longer share important
information with their family and
friends the liberal party has also
continued to buy ads for meta a tool
heavily used during election campaigns
so the Liberals are the party that uses
digital advertising the most of all the
major parties in the last election
campaign the Liberals spent almost as
much on digital ads as they did on TV ad
Global News asked for an interview with
the Heritage minister to discuss the new
proposal but she wasn't made available
although she'll participate in the
upcoming public consultation process
nathu all right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks Mackenzie
Canada's economy gone off to a weak
start in the second quarter of this year
shrinking unexpectedly statistics Canada
says the economy contracted at an
annualized rate of 0.2 percent with GDP
growth sitting flat in July that's lower
than the bank of Canada's forecast of
1.5 percent growth earlier this year the
Slowdown is largely due to declines in
housing investment International exports
and household spending and could help
hold interest rates steady the Bank of
Canada is expected to make a new
decision next week
the Canada Revenue Agency has fired 120
employees for claiming a two thousand
dollar a month Federal covid-19 benefit
the CRA is reviewing about 600 cases of
current employees receiving the Canada
emergency response benefit the Serb was
meant to help people whose jobs were
lost or downgraded as a result of Public
Health restrictions it has found only 30
legitimate cases for employees who had
temporary or student contracts
as tens of thousands stand by waiting to
hear when they may be able to return
home officials in the Northwest
Territories are preparing for what's
being called an extreme wind event this
weekend gusts of more than 60 kilometers
per hour are expected in some areas
raising fears the Wildfire situation
near communities like Hay River and Fort
Simpson could worsen Jamie Dahl reports
days displays have turned into weeks but
the agony of uncertainty at home is
carrying more weight than the long
weight itself for this Hay River couple
forced to hit pause in Calgary we
actually thought our house was gone
there at one point the fire is right at
our doorstep we have we have good
friends that have lost everything I
think it's just been a miracle that our
town is still there we're very very
thankful to all the people there
that are
working hard to save it
what you're seeing in the distance there
is a whole lot of trees that have blown
down that's of course a result of these
wind events the situation in Hay River
is at a critical point high winds and
hot temperatures are fueling the risk
wind that could potentially push this
fire uh at its easternmost Point more
than 20 kilometers to the East and it
could also certainly uh be a significant
challenge for the town of Hay River and
surrounding neighborhoods
on Sunday the air we experienced a
similar wind event threatening the
remaining few structures in the already
decimated nearby Hamlet of Enterprise
resident firefighters are still there
protecting what's left
and next door Volunteers in Hay River
are hoping to help prevent a similar
catastrophe we're gonna hold it until we
so we can't anymore Aaron Campbell
stayed back and is helping support those
firefighters on the front lines in Hay
River yeah I miss my kids he misses the
people that make this town a community
too and while he admits is not safe for
them there now he's optimistic A change
is going to come I hope people come back
to their homes and don't decide to help
them maybe remember because everyone
needs and needs needs you just as much
as anything else it's the people that
makes you ever great the town has been
through two evacuations this summer and
a devastating flood last year Simon and
Candy also wonder if some may just
decide to pull up Stakes for good but
right now all they can think about is
going home
Jamie dog Global News Calgary
Quebec's new rules for online short-term
rental platforms come into effect today
the province brought in a new law and
new finds after seven people were killed
in a huge fire in March they were in an
old building in Old Montreal that
contained several illegal airbnbs as
Mike Armstrong reports there appears to
be some progress but Watchdog groups say
many are still floating the law
the new rules in Quebec put more of the
burden for policing short-term rental
platforms on those platforms themselves
as of September 1st they're supposed to
make sure all lodgings listed on their
sites are legal the fines they face if
illegal listings are found up to a
hundred thousand dollars per listing
it's been a long time coming JJ fuser is
with an advocacy group fairbnb it says
for companies like Airbnb ignoring
illegal listings has been lucrative
business well those platforms now have
to ensure each listing has an up-to-date
provincial registration number Airbnb
has said it was up to the government to
monitor but fuser says the platforms
should and always could do it themselves
this technology companies these
platforms have always been technically
able to do this kind of cross-check
it was this tragedy in March that led to
change Flames swept through a
century-old building seven people were
killed six of them were staying in
rented airbnbs the building shouldn't
have had any the city has a ban on
short-term rentals in Old Montreal
now being forced to control their
listings isn't going over well with
Airbnb in a statement to Global News it
says quote the new rules are a
complicated and ineffective framework
that will make it harder for hosts to
welcome guests and nearly impossible for
platforms to properly meet new
requirements
materials mayor disagrees and says the
city has added inspectors to find rule
Breakers what we want is ideally would
be your legal we catch you you pay
you're out that's what we want feels
like we have a gun on our head Danny
papino runs we Chalet it has listings
for about 2 300 Cottages he says for the
smaller platforms the new rules were
brought in too quickly we're three
employees right now it's like you know
we can't validate that many listings
overnight papino also says the new fines
don't fix the problem with the March
fire deaths had more to do with missing
fire escapes and fire alarms he says
than how they were listed online Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal
a community in Saskatchewan is about to
Mark a painful anniversary nearly a year
ago miles Sanderson went on a killing
spree taking 11 lives between James
Smith Cree Nation and the community of
Weldon since the tragedy it's been an
especially unique struggle for two women
who knew him and his brother more than
most Nathaniel Dove has more on the
widows of miles and Damien Sanderson and
the questions they're still trying to
answer and a warning this story contains
disturbing details
what made him do that to my family my
kids a year later Skye Sanderson is
still trying to make sense of what
happened I was wonderful
why my life is the way it is now
what did I
where did we go wrong
like we always knew to stay away from
miles on September 4th 2022 miles
Sanderson went on a rampage killing 11
people and injuring 17 at James Smith
Cree Nation and in nearby Weldon
Saskatchewan one of the first killed his
brother Damien survived by Sky and their
children they come home in the front
door and Damian would hide underneath a
blanket and give them all starts as they
come in one by one Brothers on very
different paths Damien had struggled
with the law but was working to be a
good father and husband miles had nearly
60 convictions and was vicious to his
ex-partner I don't know why he was
coming back to get mad at me
didn't make sense
so
something that I'm piecing together
right now Vanessa Burns telling Global's
Ashley Stewart she thought miles might
have killed her but not so many others
that's what
kept me I gave him a chance to be a dad
and then he'd always want to get back
with me some somehow somewhere
but I think this last time he had a plan
like
just something was different miles
stabbed her mother Joyce three times and
killed her father Earl why didn't I go
and I said the only reason I know why is
because my grandkids were downstairs I
didn't want to leave them there are
plans for a monument to Earl to replace
the flowers honoring the veteran they
miss him I was with him this time last
year and I think just because I know
what's going to happen you know and I
didn't last year Vanessa says she's
relieved because she knows miles would
never leave her alone if he were still
alive
but they say they still don't feel safe
coroners are investigating and RCMP have
clarified the timeline but admitted any
answers may have died with miles
after so much sudden loss survivors are
slowly trying to move on I want a home
again
and I'm not going back to that house
Nathaniel Dove Global News
in Washington more members of the
far-right extremist group The Proud boys
have been sentenced for their role in
the January 6 Capital riots today a
judge sentenced Dominic pizzola to 10
years in prison and handed 18 years to
Ethan Nordeen a day earlier former
leaders Joseph Biggs and Zachary reel
were given 17 and 15 years respectively
they're among the longest sentences
handed down so far to those convicted
for the 2021 attack on Congress to stop
the certification of Joe Biden's
presidency the group's top leader
Enrique tario is set to be sentenced
next week
the politics of Aging coming up the
renewed concerns about some senior
lawmakers in the U.S
in the U.S a tough to watch moment
played out in front of TV cameras this
week as Republican senator Mitch
McConnell appeared to suffer a medical
episode in public it's the second time
it's happened this summer The Incident
raises concerns about the fitness of
some of the most senior political
leaders in the U.S including the
country's 80 year old president Jackson
prosco reports
what are your thoughts on running for
re-election in 2026 what are my thoughts
about what running for re-election in
2016.
okay
in that moment 81 year old Mitch
McConnell appeared to freeze all right
I'm sorry you all we're gonna need a
minute soon after the Republican senator
collected himself but the same thing
happened last month for nearly 20
seconds okay Mitch
in both cases McConnell insisted there
was no problem
he and other U.S politicians can't
escape questions about their age and
fitness to serve how are you feeling
90 year old Democrat Dianne Feinstein
hospitalized twice this year at times
she has appeared disoriented but is
still voting in the Senate just say I
okay just
fine right now the Senate is the most
privileged Nursing Home in the country
in the U.S pressure to retire rarely
comes from inside the world of politics
there's sort of a gentleman's and gentle
women's agreement in the Senate that you
get to serve as long as you want you've
reached the Pinnacle of your career just
ask soon to be 81 year old President Joe
Biden I know I'm 198 years old
who is serious about supporting other
senior leaders I spoke to Mitch he's a
friend and so I'm confident he's going
to be back to his old self Biden's own
age is a major liability for voters 77
percent of Americans think he's too old
to effectively serve another term that
hasn't stopped his re-election campaign
there are going to be tens of millions
of Americans who will prefer a guy who's
getting ready to turn 82 in 2024 to a
younger Donald Trump when Trump is only
four years younger so long as voters
keep electing elderly candidates there's
little incentive to make age anything
more than just a number as for getting
politicians to recognize when they've
reached their own best before dates it
often takes pressure from their own
families
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
ahead a powerful typhoon brings Hong
Kong to a near standstill
Greek firefighters have rescued 25
migrants trapped by a wildfire burning
for two weeks the men from Syria Iraq
and Lebanon were taken to a safer area
in the back of an emergency service
truck the wildfire in avros is Europe's
deadliest Blaze this summer killing at
least 20 people all but one of the Dead
are believed to have been migrants who
crossed over from Turkey
millions in Hong Kong and Southeastern
China are under severe storm warnings
tonight as typhoon Salah threatens to
become the strongest storm to hit the
region in a decade
heavy rain and strong winds made their
way through Hong Kong today where
officials issued their highest storm
alert urging people to stay inside and
away from Windows schools and businesses
have been closed in the region and
hundreds of flights canceled the storm's
eye is expected to make landfall just
south of Hong Kong
in the UK controversial Egyptian
businessman Muhammad al-fayed who
clashed with the British royal family
has died the billionaire was known for
owning a major British department store
chain London's Fulham Football Club and
the Hotel Ritz Paris but he was also in
the spotlight over the death of Princess
Diana his eldest son Dodie also died in
the car crash that killed her he alleged
that the tragedy was not an accident
that it was a murder orchestrated by the
royal family Al Fayed was 94.
Pope Francis arrived in Mongolia today
for his first trip through the
predominantly Buddhist country after a
10-hour flight the pope was met by a
ceremonial welcome at the airport before
being driven to mongolia's Capital where
he was greeted by singing school
children the visit is seen as a show of
support for one of the smallest and
newest Catholic communities in the world
and an attempt to maintain a presence
between China and Russia both of which
have strained relations with the Vatican
next on the edge of elimination what's
on the line for Canada's men as they try
to break through at the world basketball
championship
[Music]
a shocking loss for Team Canada today at
the FIBA World Cup as Brazil handed them
their first loss of the tournament the
Canadians now have a must-win game
against Spain on Sunday in order to move
on to the next round and have a chance
at qualifying for the Olympics up until
today Canada was on track for a
breakthrough tournament easily beating
the first three opponents but as Eric
Sorensen reports the team now finds
itself in a similar situation to
previous years on the verge of
elimination
a team that looked like World beaters
were beaten by Brazil a big setback for
Canada's hopes in basketball's World Cup
for Olympic qualifying and for putting
the Demons of past disappointments
behind them reminiscent of crushing
losses to Venezuela in 2015 and czechia
in 2021 that kept the men's team out of
the last two Olympics it's a very
different team from those two teams Alex
Adams is in Jakarta following the
Canadian men's team he sees Canada as a
power in international basketball now
led by Shea gilders Alexander one of the
best players in the world definitely a
meteoric rise he's essentially improved
every single year he's he's been in the
NBA he's just a phenomenal phenomenal
player and the best player Canada's had
since Steve Nash Canada is missing some
top players Jamal Murray and Andrew
Wiggins but such is the depth of
Canadian men's basketball now that the
team trounced France Lebanon and Latvia
putting them in position to still
Advance at the World Cup if they can in
their next game beat Spain in the top
ranked team in the world Adams thinks
the Canadian team can bounce back the
talent level is is just way more than
it's ever been and it only seems to be
growing and it would just beaten so much
to this program if they are able to make
it to the Olympics and if they can win
on Sunday Canada will be one step closer
to making the Olympics for the first
time in 23 years Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
a lot is on the line there that is
global national for this Friday night
I'm nitu Garcia tonight's your Canada is
The Bishop's Falls trestle over the
exploits River in Newfoundland and
Labrador spanning more than 280 meters
this is the province's longest Trestle
we love seeing your Canada please email
it to viewers globalnational.com thanks
so much for watching and hope you'll
join us again tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
thank you